and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review first of all I ain't
never going to tell you that there are a
split your eighth notes spoilers where I
think people with their big armor and
their longswords and fighting all those
windmills oh wait this is pannier can we
fiercest please called zombie dick
wherever you wanted to stop me I think
was a zombie once I was part of the
Oprah book and the only survivor is this
boy with Harrelson dressed up like
Crocodile Dundee this really hot chick
and Little Miss Sunshine that's right
Little Miss Sunshine is in a zombie
movie it is about three tiny I always
said the Olsen twins should be in a
zombie movie or was it a vampire movie
either way they suck the life out of
everybody who watches them but I did
grease so our four main characters are
trying to run away from the evil zombies
way because these zombies are actually
fast what are some bees always so slow
in other movies the people are always
like run road runners they eat your
brains
all four of our characters have their
own specific boobs like the boy wants to
see fam Z the high chief wants to take
Little Miss Sunshine to an amusement
park and what a Nelson just wants a
Twinkie his entire quadrant the whole
movie is just looking for a Twinkie my
life looking for a Twinkie once he was
my best friend so anyway on the way to
the amusement park they drop by a
celebrity's house and now I won't ruin
which celebrity it is for now let's just
call him mr. X so Bill Murray finds out
that all these people are sleeping in
his house and it turns out he survived a
zombie attack because he dressed up like
a zombie and no worries like
they say he was lost in translation
anyway they make it all the way to the
theme park and the girls are like I
wonder who's truly the brainiest people
here so does that be fried to attack the
amusement to park and we get that's
really action see while also we joined
some right now what I don't know we're
doing something it oh yeah that's stand
you can tell this is a really good movie
it's just like you miss sunshine each
turn of the Dead mummies need to be
mixed to a shot of the Dead like Shaun
of the Dead mix with Dreamgirls
a week they'll scold later this is
jittery boom see Jay you can help me
make sure that the Germans or Wizard of
Oz the Wizard of Oz I mean eternal
you
Oh